you
[Music]
all right welcome everyone so welcome to
MS Rai we're very happy to have you with
us for the next three days I think we
have a really nice scientific program
put together for you so I hope you know
the topic of the workshop is is deep
learning so you know I think many people
in the room agrees that it's one of the
great surgical challenge of our time to
understand what is actually going on in
in deep learning and what we are trying
to do here is to bring different
perspectives on the problem you know
both core machine learning but also
mathematics and theoretical computer
science ok so before we start with with
the actual scientific program I have a
couple of logistical comments to make as
the first one I guess the most important
is a Wi-Fi so you have the instructions
over there and the password is ms event
empty set 12 T G okay it's written here
another thing if you guys want you know
during the break to find a whiteboard or
a table to work with people the two
rooms next door lounge rooms for you to
use so you know feel free to to go there
you can't enter the main building by
yourself you need someone with a badge
too too you know
swipe you in so you can ask one of the
nice ladies of the registration to what
you get in or you can ask idea and I and
will help you you can also just go to
the reception and tell them that you
register that the AI Institute and they
will let you in for the lunch today and
tomorrow it will be outside there are
tents set up today we will also do a
group picture outside so you know just
at the end of the first session of this
morning don't escape you know follow me
and we'll go take a group picture and
finally the last logistical thing is we
have a reception at the Chile Museum
tomorrow night that should be really
nice so you know you're all welcome to
attend I highly recommend it there will
be a bus leaving from here at just after
the last session if your internal please
try to get there by yourself rather than
taking the bus because it's limited
space but you know if you can't do it
otherwise you you're welcome to come in
the bus okay
so that's all I had to say about
logistical things so now it's my great
pleasure to introduce our first keynote
speaker
Peter Bartlett so Peter is a is a
professor of computer science and
statistics at UC Berkeley is also the
associate director of the Simon's
Institute for the theory of computing
for now a year or more but more
importantly has been a leader in
learning theory for several decades I
guess now and he has written a book on
surgical foundations of neural networks
20 years ago ok so so deep learning is
not exactly news to him and and I'm
looking forward to see you know what
perspective it will tell us about ok
please join me to welcome Peter thanks
Sebastian thanks for introduction and
thanks a lot for inviting me really
delighted to be here I guess
20 years ago things weren't deep so you
know it's very different okay so this is
joint work at the the main substance of
my talk is joint work with Phil long at
Google gobble ago she and Barcelona and
Alexandre Ziegler who's a PhD student in
statistics at Berkeley and what I want
to talk about is this I think one of the
most surprising and mysterious phenomena
that has been brought to light by these
deep neural networks and it's this
observation that these networks can be
trained to give zero training error for
regression loss so they're really
interpolating the data and still perform
pretty well in their predictive accuracy
so and I guess the striking thing you
know all all real problems are noisy but
the striking thing is you can add more
noise and still have reasonable
performance of these things so this is
this is a plot from a paper a bunch of
guys at Google a couple of years ago
looking at a particular image
classification problem so this is so far
10 and
on the top plot the y axis is showing
how many passes through the data is
needed to get a perfect fit for
different three different architectures
and on the x axis is the amount of label
corruption so over here is the actual
cipher 10a data and over here is where
the labels are randomly chosen from from
the set of size 10 and you see that you
know it takes a little longer to get to
a perfect fit as you have more more
noise down here is showing test error on
the same the same x axis so you have
with with no added noise of course it's
you know a noisy noisy data set with no
added noise you get particular levels of
performance and a gradual degradation as
you as you add noise and the striking
thing is I mean both of these are
actually labeling the the loss used is
miss classification but in fact turns
out when you consider the regression
loss they're essentially interpolating
the data in all of these cases alright
so you know if you think about a point
here you you've got an architecture that
can fit perfectly to the data it's it's
essentially interpolating every every
why why I in the in the training sample
and yet the performance is not that much
worse than then the sort of performance
people see on this problem with you know
carefully tuned prediction methods so
that's really striking right we're
adding noise we're and we're actually
interpolating the data and getting
reasonable reasonable performance out
maybe not totally state-of-the-art but
but pretty good and there's a bunch of
other examples of this sort there's a
very nice paper by Bill consumer and
Mendel showing a similar phenomenon in
lots of other other settings beyond just
the deep learning one so you know I
think this is really a striking
phenomenon there and and the crazy thing
is there's no trade-off between this
classical you know fit to the training
data versus the complexity of
family of prediction rules okay so you
know it's it's certainly fitting as well
as you possibly could but but this it
apparently is benign from the
perspective of predictive accuracy okay
and and of course the classical view of
prediction methodology is to aim for a
trade-off between the fit to the
training data and the complexity of a
prediction rule so maybe we're concerned
with the squared error in a regression
problem right we want to choose a
prediction rule f hat that has good
performance on the training sample and
we we trade that off with the complexity
of that F hat which might be the number
of parameters the length of the vector
of parameters it might be if if f hat
comes from a reproducing kernel Hilbert
space we might want to keep the norm of
the of the function in that arc h s
small perhaps with a regularization term
or if we're doing something some other
nonparametric thing you know like a
kernel smoothing method we might want to
choose our bandwidth appropriately but
you know whatever it is we're we're
always in this classically always in
this regime of trading off the
complexity of our prediction rule
against the fit to the training data and
and you know that's what you you
certainly do
if you move beyond the the parametric
case if you move move to the case of of
having a number of parameters growing
with the sample size and if we're
talking about interpolating prediction
of course we're in that in that regime
okay and you know these these slides are
borrowed from a tutorial that Sascha and
I did in a couple months ago at the
Simon's Institute but and and you know
I'm picking on two textbooks here but
they all many many of these statistical
learning texts say the same kind of
thing right if you fit too well then you
won't generalize well you know
interpolating fits are unlikely to
predict the future data well at all this
is a bad approach because it leads to a
function that interpolates the data
which of course is a terrible thing
okay so you know the classical wisdom is
that a prediction rule shouldn't fit too
well but deep networks seem to to
violate this this statistical wisdom
they're fitting noisy data perfectly and
still predicting well and so you know
what I think is this is this is a really
fascinating phenomenon that that has
been brought to light by deep learning
practice I want to say a little bit
about some of the previous work in this
direction and some of the history so
this is something that that came up at
the program on machine learning two
years ago at the at the Symons Institute
there was a tutorial that Russ
salakhutdinov gave on you know what
practitioners do in in this area and he
he pointed out this is sort of
phenomenon and they're a bunch of a
bunch of folks we got talking about this
you know Daniel Daniel Hsu Misha Belkin
Matus tel gaskey and you know several
several several of us they're at this at
this program and there's been sort of a
whole lot of work in the in the two
years since since then I think it's
really quite a fascinating fascinating
observation so first that I that I think
came out of this was this work of Belkin
su & Mitra looking at nearest nearest
neighbor like methods so of course one
nearest neighbor is an interpolating
prediction rule right you you pick the
label of the the nearest neighbor you
know you're getting the the training
sample labelled exactly right you know
if it's if you don't have any two points
in the sample the same but it doesn't
have this property this this property of
near optimal predictive accuracy you you
get within something like a factor of
two of the pay's risk with with the
nearest neighbor rule but but this paper
showed that you could do something
similar a simplicity all sort of
interpolation right so divide divide
things up into simplices defined by the
training sample and and then pick a
linear prediction rule that
does exactly the predicts according to
the to the data on the vertices and and
interpolate sort of nearly in between
and it and as the dimension grows you
get performance that gets closer and
closer to the to the the optimal alright
so you know this is one example of a
nonparametric method that performs well
I guess in high dimensions kernel
smoothing kinds of methods with these
crazy kernels that that go to infinity
at the at the training points it turns
out for an appropriate choice of the
bandwidth parameter for these things you
can even get not just get you know the
optimal predictive accuracy but or
something approaching that but you can
get the minimax rates for for many
problems so this is you know really
really fascinating case also and then
linear regression and you know there's a
there's a much bigger list that I guess
falls off the bottom of my slide here
but so there's this work on on looking
that Sasha will tell us about this and
and subsequent work in his talk later
today but there's this work on on
kernels that so linear regression in an
arc HS where the kernel is defined as
some nonlinear function of euclidean
inner product and what you can say there
this is in a regime where the the
dimension of the input space is growing
with the sample size and then this work
that and andraia is going to tell us
about and again subsequent work later in
in the meeting is using the using tools
from from random matrix theory to look
at what happens in a linear regression
setting as the dimension and sample size
go to infinity together and also I guess
I guess the nonlinear cases well
there're there are results there we're
going going beyond just the case
of linear regression here and we'll hear
about some of those those results what I
want to tell you about is is some non
asymptotic results so understanding you
know I guess the simplest possible
prediction setting where we might hope
to explain this this phenomenon and it's
the case of linear regression we get a
rather complete characterization for the
linear regression problems that we study
of this phenomenon of benign overfitting
right we can see exactly when it does
and doesn't occur that you get you get
near optimal predictive accuracy so
we'll look at those those results and
and why they arise and then I'll say a
little bit about deep learning about
what other what are the gaps right the
hurdles to overcome before we can apply
the same results in that in the deep
learning so I'm setting before we can
hope to I guess and I want to say a few
words about adversarial examples as well
sort of a kind of simple observation
there okay so that's the agenda so yeah
as I say we we decided to look at this
simplest simplest setting where this
phenomenon of benign overfitting might
occur it's the setting of linear
regression so let me define a little
carefully what we're what we're talking
about here so we have XY pairs the X's
are in some inner product space or
Hilbert space and you can just think of
it as finite dimensional but we're
always going to be concerned with the
dimension being large compared to the
sample size large at least as big as a
sample size and and the response
variable Y is the thing we want to
predict for most of what I'm presenting
in a precise way just think of the XY
pairs as being jointly Gaussian and mean
zero and I'll say I'll explain how we
can extend that to sub just in case a
little later okay and then the the kind
of three pieces of notation that we need
for for our linear regression problem
are as follows the first is the most
important is the
variance matrix Sigma of the X's right
and and in particular we're going to
think about the spectral decomposition
and the crucial thing here is these
eigenvalues lambda I right so keep this
notation in your head through most of
the rest of the talk the lambda rise
here are the the the eigenvalues of this
covariance matrix and they're in
decreasing order so lambda 1.is
corresponds to the variance in the first
principal component direction the
highest variance direction of the x's
lambda 2.is the next highest variance
direction and so on right and and this
turns out it's you know this is the
geometry that's crucial for this benign
overfitting phenomenon okay so the this
is one piece of notations theta star is
the optimal parameter vector so the
minimizer of this expected squared error
and and we're assuming it has a finite
norm so that's the best that's the
parameter vector that gives us our best
performance that's what we're competing
with and Sigma squared is the expected
squared error for this optimal linear
prediction rule okay so that's the those
three things define our linear
regression problem the sort of estimator
that we're interested in is the minimum
norm estimator so you know we're in a
setting where we can thinking of a
setting where we can interpolate what's
the and and typically that means we're
under determine and there's a whole set
of these linear prediction rules that
could could interpolate which one are we
going to pick we're going to pick the
one with the smallest norm right the
parameter theta that has a smallest norm
okay so what does that mean we've got a
sample of size n and the notation I'm
going to use is very much like the
finite dimensional notation you learn in
your undergraduate class of linear
regression right so X is our data matrix
with think of it as having n rows that
are our elements of our hilbert space
and y is is our vector of responses and
our estimator now because we're
concerned with the case where you know
the least squares on the on the sample
is achievable by a whole subspace of
so we're interested in the minimum
minimum norm parameter that achieves
that squared error on the sample okay so
that's our feeder hand and and you know
it's the solution to these under
determine normal equations that has
minimum norm so we replace this this X
transpose X is is ranked efficient we
pick the take the pseudo-inverse of that
so we're picking the smallest norm
vector that satisfies those normal
equations okay so that's that's what our
estimated looks like it's X transpose X
pseudo inverse X transpose Y the kind of
criterion we're concerned with for these
problems is the access prediction error
all right so so we want to compete with
the optimal prediction error this men
overall all Theater of this expected
squared error and we're interested in
the excess risk that our theta hat
achieves of course that optimal
prediction error is achieved by this
theta star so we're just in that
difference and you know the quadratic
losses is beautiful to work with the
cross terms vanish we end up with
something that's just this quadratic
form in the error of our parameter
estimate right so it's theta hat our
parameter estimate minus theta star the
optimal thing and it's it's it's norm
squared in in this sense defined by the
the Sigma matrix the covariance matrix
okay so the covariance matrix that tells
is something that tells us the how
important different parameter directions
are right and if we think of that
decomposition spectral decomposition of
our covariance matrix the lambda i's are
telling us you know which are the
directions where we really have to get
theta star right right in which of the
directions where and Flandre is very
small we can be completely wrong in our
parameter estimates and still do very
well in in the in terms of predictive
accuracy still still get a very good
compete very well with theta stars
predictive accuracy okay
all right so so now let me tell you
about you know the this characterization
of when we can when we can have this
benign overfitting so so we're interests
in the overfitting regime so so we're we
have the the rank of X's is at least n
so we can't get 0 0 error on the on the
sample and that means that we're we're
nailing it on every example right each
for each for each I why I is equal to X
I transpose theta hat okay and and the
question we're asking is you know when
can we take all of the label noise
that's in these Y's and inject it into
the parameter estimate the theta hat in
in this sort of a way and still have
good predictive accuracy on subsequent
XY pairs you know in terms of the
expected squared error okay so here's
the theorem and it says for any linear
regression problem so what's really
crucial here as I as I said is the
parameter eigen values of our covariance
matrix Sigma Lambda N greater than zero
just means we can interpolate so there
are two notions of effective rank of
matrices that pop up here and I'm going
to define them in a moment so you know
they're this little R K and another R K
that arises later the idea is we
consider the K heaviest directions of
our covariance so the the biggest values
of these lambda KS they define certain
directions we're going to ignore those
heaviest directions and concentrate on
the tail of the covariance matrix so
look at the subspace that's orthogonal
to the highest variance directions and
there's a certain dimension of that
subspace we consider it's this K star
that's defined in terms of a certain
effective rank we'll see what that is
later on so after we ignore the first K
star highest variance directions then we
have you know the effective rank of the
covariance matrix in all the other
directions that better be large compared
to
so the excess risk that we see is
bounded by you know this term is a kind
of a classical thing not so interesting
this is the term that that arises from
taking all the noise in our labels and
putting them into our parameter
estimates so we better have the case
star up here small compared to end and
we better have the effect of rank
you know define in a certain way large
compared to N in order to have that
excess risk small so it's a high
probability upper bound there's a
matching lower bound in the sense that
that second term the interesting one you
know can't be improved by more than a
constant and the first term you can show
that this r0 of Sigma needs to be small
compared to n you know modulo a log
factor it's saying this ratio between R
0 and n can't be can't be too big or
you're in trouble alright so in some
sense you know every term here is is
essential but in particular you know the
most interesting one is the impact of
the noise in the labels on the
predictive accuracy and and you know
it's this K star over n plus n over R K
star ok so what are what are these
mysterious RK is it's the effective rank
of the the covariance matrix in the
subspace that's orthogonal to these
heaviest K directions so we're looking
at the tail of the covariance matrix
right these smaller smaller principal
components and these little R K and
capital RK are defined like this so
we've got remember ordered eigenvalues
we drop off the first K and look after
those K at the sequence of eigenvalues
and little R K is the one norm divided
by the infinity norm of that tail and
big R K is the one norm squared divided
by the 2 norm squared ok so so you know
just thinking of little R K it's saying
it's say you know one norm divided by
infinity norm is how many of those
biggest biggest ones in the in the tail
do I see as the the mass of what's
remaining so we can these two are pretty
closely related capital R K is bigger
than little R K but not too much bigger
and you can think of them as I mean we
call them the effective rank you know if
you have a finite rank matrix then these
things so for instance for the identity
in in P dimensions you know the effect
of rank is P but they also impose some
some sort of a symmetry condition as
well so if you've got a a matrix that
has rank P then you can write these
little R right little R as the rank
times some notion of symmetry and the
same for big R with a slightly different
notion of symmetry and these kind of
symmetry measures lie between 1 and
something small okay so it's the rank
times some notion of symmetry it might
be much smaller than the actual rank but
but certainly no bigger this one yeah
yeah so right so the little little are
the smaller one needs to be bigger than
the sample size in and once you first
cross that point where where you've got
all right so if we have if we plot out
you know the lambda rise is a function
of I and we have some sequence that goes
it's supposed to be monotone decreasing
goes down like this when we first get to
a point you know maybe it's here k star
where the ratio of the one norm of
what's left in this vector to the
infinity norm the first one exceeds n so
we've got kind of something that has a
mass that's at least n times this first
guy that defines the K star and then the
N over capital R K star is another one
of these ratios of the effective rank of
of what's remaining from that K star
onwards
yeah then you'll never to it yes so so
you know if you have a finite rank I
final rank matrix then then you know
you're in trouble right you won't so the
are the the capital R K star is is no
bigger than the rank so you'll get an N
over and over some finite thing in the
service you must have a very large
that's exactly right the intuition is
that we're taking the noise from the
wise and we're embedding them in this
part of the space in this subspace
that's orthogonal to where all the
action is happening so here we have big
eigenvalues we've got to be careful
about estimating estimating the
parameters in these directions in these
directions we can be we don't have to
care so much and actually it's important
there are many of these directions
because that's where all the noise has
to go the energy of the noise is
proportional to N and that's what the N
over capital R K star comes from well
you know I get get into that in a bit
more detail but to be part of it is
benign and the rest you will be able to
control so controlling the noise in
terms of having a Ana procure attest
Omotesando
is a classical problem you know because
our case star needs to be of moved on
from that's right now k star needs to be
small compared to n so we're that's just
like the finite dimensional setting and
and you know in in terms of being able
to overfit you really need to have this
tail as somewhere to to stash all of the
noise that you're getting from from
overfitting there from from from a
perfect fit you can build this this is
great I can stop here and not show the
rest of my slides you can engineer the
tail exactly right yeah ok so so I'm
going to be able to skip over all of
these so the the mix of eigenvalues
plays two roles here it tells us you
know we had this this result that the
excess prediction error
the excess risk is bounded by a
quadratic form in the error of our
parameter estimate and the lambda rise
determine you know how how important
areas in different directions are but
the lambda rise also determine how the
label noise is distributed through
throughout that theta hat right we get
we get more of the label noise appearing
in these in these higher variance
directions than we do in the in the
lower variance directions so there's a
balance here that we have to that we
have to meet right and and the intuition
is to avoid harming the prediction
accuracy we have to have that noise
energy distributed across many many
unimportant directions we can't
concentrate it on you know a few small
directions so we have to be in this
regime where we have lots of lots and
lots of parameter directions many more
than the sample size so thinking about
the different terms that appear in that
bound the number of nonzero eigenvalues
certainly has to be large compared to n
because of that n over capital RK term
the sum of them has to be small compared
to and I mean that's a classical thing
we just want to make sure that the the
kind of scale is appropriate and the
number of these small values small
eigenvalues needs to be large compared
to n we need to have a long a long tail
here and they need to be you know
roughly equal in in magnitude right they
can be more asymmetric if we have many
more than n of them okay so that's
that's what happens with this with this
characterization let me say a little bit
about how it arises and you know I'm
being kind of quite intuitive here in
the in the explanation so the the first
step is is a kind of an obvious thing we
can split up our expected loss into two
components one that corresponds to what
the optimal linear prediction rule would
have said and and one that corresponds
to everything else right so we'll call
that Y minus X transpose P star we'll
call that the the noise and there are
two components now of the
the excess expected loss you know due to
these two pieces one the first component
is is due to the signal it's just
because this theta hat is a distorted
version of theta star because we don't
we get a distorted view of the
covariance of of X and the second
component this the piece due to the
noise is because we're taking all of the
noise in our you know our labels and
putting them into the theater hat so the
first component is kind of easy to deal
with it's it's really quite a classical
thing even if we're in a high
dimensional setting the second is much
more problematic that's where the heart
of problem really lies and we're asking
as I say when can we take all that
energy in the label noise put it in
theater hat and not hurt predictive
accuracy
okay so let's call that excess the extra
piece beyond what the optimal linear
prediction rule would have said let's
call that epsilon so for our finite
sample we have our XY pairs this matrix
ax has one row for each of the N
examples and and Y is the response
variable so epsilon is a vector of
length n that that's the the additional
piece you know what's left over when we
think about our estimator it's linear in
Y so we can split it up into those two
pieces the piece from the signal and the
piece from the noise and the excess risk
we saw you know it depends on the error
in our parameters scaled appropriately
according to these lambda rise in the
different directions okay so you know we
have that this thing's concentrated
around two pieces one that depends on
the signal and one that depends on the
noise and that's the critical piece and
you know it's an easy exercise to show
to show this that the crucial term is
this one that comes from the noise
that's the trace of you know an x
transpose x pseudo-inverse times the
covariance okay so that's the piece we
have to analyze and just to give you
some intuition about the analysis of it
you know our excess risk tells us how
our errors in our parameters affect
things we we write that as this spectral
decomposition and then split the
directions into the heavy ones these
these
biggest eigenvalues you know with some
cutoff K and the light once you know the
tale of the of the eigenvalues and then
we we can consider what happens to the
eigenvalues of this X transpose X the
thing that appears in our in our
estimator so the smallest ones of those
n eigenvalue okay the n non-zero
argument so this is like a covariance
estimate right this X transpose X but
it's going to be ranked efficient
they're only going to be n directions
where anything happens because we only
have a sample of size n things are zero
outside of that of that subspace in that
subspace we have in n eigenvalues it
turns out when we when we have this
effective rank bigger than n then the
smallest of those nonzero eigenvalues
are all about the same they're
concentrated around a particular value
call it row right so once we hit that
that threshold then things are nicely
concentrated and the big ones are big
ones are concentrated as well but
they're sort of easy to deal with okay
so once we hit that threshold then all
of the nonzero eigenvalues you know are
under control in some sense and so we
have that you know all of those little
eigenvalues are bigger than some value
row so if we consider the gram matrix
you know X X transpose instead of X
transpose X this is an N by n matrix and
it's got all of its eigenvalues bigger
than row okay and and you know that's
that's some useful intuition to have
right our estimate is X transpose X
pseudo inverse X transpose Y so when
we're taking 1 over the eigenvalues in
those non-zero directions with that
pseudo inverse we're taking 1 over
something that's at least as big as row
ok so this is you know reminiscent of
doing Ridge regression where we take X
transpose X plus Rho times I we're
ensuring that all the eigenvalues are
bigger than some and some minimum value
and and something similar is going on
here kind of for free right ok so so you
know remember we've got all of our
eigenvalues once we're beyond
this point we've got all of those
remaining eigenvalues concentrated
around this this value row so when we
think about the minimum norm estimator
and in particular the piece of it that's
due to the noise epsilon then then what
happens where's the energy from the
noise go so we can split things up into
these different directions according to
our spectral decomposition of Sigma the
noise energy that comes from X transpose
epsilon in a VI direction right is going
to be proportional to end times lambda R
I write because of this X X scaling and
then when we put that through this X
transpose X inverse it's scaled by no
more than 1 over Rho squared squared
because they're considering energy
rights like we're looking at the
quadratic quadratic form right so so you
know if Rho is small that gets blown up
a lot but you know it's it's scaled in
this way the impact on the prediction
error of course is scaled by this factor
of another factor of lambda right and so
you know all together we get a bound on
the prediction error due to that VI
component that's something like n times
proportional to n times lambda I squared
divided by this Rho squared right that's
that's what we get from from Direction
VI turns out this is a this is a good
argument to make when we're at in the
tail but for the big eigenvalues this is
really sloppy and we can do much better
in those heavy directions we can get
something that's no more than 1 over N
and that's kind of a classical thing but
then add up over all of these directions
and we get K over N plus n times the sum
of the land dry squares over the Rho
squared which is which is exactly this
sort of form all right so that's why we
get this particular balance involving
these these eigen values at the Landers
and and the lower bound you know you can
show that the excess expected loss is is
pretty much the same it's at least as
big as that same that same quantity when
the eigen values are concentrated we
were in that in that regime the same the
same split into these two pieces gives
us the same so a lower bound within a
constant factor and if we're not
concentrated
then we get a lobe and that's at least a
constant so that's where the where the
theorem comes from okay so you can ask
you know so here's the result it's in
terms of those two effective ranks and
and you know in some sense they're
exactly the right the right quantity
because we can't improve things by more
than a constant factor right so you can
ask well what what sort of eigenvalues
lead to this kind of benign overfitting
so you know I've written three terms
here right corresponding vaguely
ignoring this scaling we can set these
things to one you know and just think
about think about problems linear
regression problems that have those
things set to one and then and then
wonder about you know what are the
infinite dimensional linear regression
problems in particular what are the
sequences of lambda i's for which these
other terms are going to go to 0 as n
gets large the balance right right so so
because this one's bigger than end
you're thinking so this is one notion of
effective rank that's another notion of
effective rate we want this one to be
bigger than n right and the first time
that it becomes bigger than a constant
times n then we fix K star to that value
so if this one were also a constant
times n we'd be in trouble but this one
is bigger than that one
capital R capital R is it could be it
capital R lives between little R and
little R squared right so it may be so
there are two ways in which we might get
lucky one is that the first K for which
this thing is bigger than n it's
actually bigger than its way bigger than
n right and then this thing is even
bigger and then we're in good shape but
even if this one is roughly order n this
one could be as big as a little R
squared right but it's not always you
know if we have this very symmetric
situation where they're about the same
the questions where is there like
regimes worries worse this is this is
not a this is not something that anybody
doing linear regression is studied
before right it's a bizarre thing to do
to be interpolating the data so this
sort of term you know I don't I don't
think I mean a you know apart from I
gave I gave a a partial list of the the
work in the last two years but I don't
think people people in in you know look
studying linear regression you won't you
won't find this kind of a phenomenon
study because you know being in this
regime where you're fitting the fitting
to the noise is something that nobody is
has considered as sensible until the
deep learning kind of practitioners
camera
[Music]
so you're saying like there's no work
previously that we that studies a
problem like I don't you fix Sigma to be
identity we're ready I mean like goats
like for example and this very stop when
the returner that looks like looks at
the eigenvalues like already stop being
hard compared to your right right so
early stopping is is early stopping his
you know very much analogous to
something like Ridge regression right
where where you you might be in a
nonparametric setting it might be in a
setting where that the sample size is
small compared to the dimension but you
know adding in this a penalty term for
the size of the parameters or stopping
early so you the size of your parameters
doesn't get too big you know is a is a
good way to balance the fit to the data
to the complexity of the problem here
we're not doing any sort of balancing of
the fit to the data to the complexity of
the problem because the fit to the data
is perfect and can't be improved at all
right and that's what I mean it's it's
that's the sort of regime where we're
you know people have have not thought
about it because I mean it's not it's
not I I guess one other thing you know
at a higher level I'm not advocating for
in a linear regression problem taking a
perfect fit to the data right I'm it's
not clear to me that you won't always
get a better predictive accuracy from
adding some regret some regularization
in right this might be you know an
inadmissible prediction rule in that
sense right all I'm trying to do is
understand you know it perhaps the
simplest possible setting we're
interpolating is not a crazy thing to do
our defensive dimensions with small
relatively you wanna dragons but
effectively what you are doing you're
adding a richer
exactly you're exactly doing that so
we'll see we'll see an example like that
in this what do our them how should be
exactly great okay so so you can ask you
know if we're in the infinite
dimensional setting and we want these
three terms to go to zero we can ask an
asymptote
kind of question you know when do they
when do they go to zero as the sample
size grows so we can define something as
you know our infinite dimensional our
covariance operator is asymptotically
benign if these three terms all go to
zero as as the sample size grows excuse
me
okay so if you think about lambda rise
that decrease like I to the minus alpha
yeah everything's everything's dependent
on l2p yeah yeah I mean we're using all
of the l2 is is kind of beautiful from
this for this analysis is very
particularly well - yeah that's right so
you know if we were to pick the minimum
l1 norm estimate and you know we're
working with quite a different thing are
you fixing oh so these are universal
constant the be and the in this see is
that what you mean yeah so it's now for
any be no no B and C are absolutely
constants and for any linear regression
problem you know K star is defined in
terms of that B and and you know I'm
being sort of sloppy here writing a see
you know 1 over C there are there are
just constants here right so think of C
is some absolute constant bigger than
what be yeah B depends in the sub gas in
case you know B depends on on that sub
yeah same constant so it's but yeah I
don't recall what it is for the Gaussian
yeah I'd have to look it up alright so
we asked about the asymptotics and have
very much time then if you're interested
in think about eigenvalues that decrease
like 1 over some polynomial right
polynomial of degree alpha and you know
it turns out we have to add some log
factors then you can show that you have
this nice asymptotic behavior if and
only if this alpha is 1 and the beater
is big enough to have things converge
right to have the sum of the eigenvalues
finite ok so that sounds kind of crazy
right the lambda eyes have to be right
at the edge of where we can where there
summable it sounds like a very peculiar
kind of situation but turns out if you
think about the the dimension as
changing with the sample size right so
if we think about restricting ourselves
to a finite but growing dimension then
actually it's very easy to satisfy the
conditions and you know this Ridge
regression sort of equivalence Ridge
regression example is a nice one so
think of it a case where these
eigenvalues are something decreasing
fast like e to the minus K you know not
so important what this rapidly
decreasing sequence is plus some
constant right a constant out to some
point P so then this thing is is benign
so has this asymptotic satisfies this
condition that asymptotically the excess
risk goes to 0 as long as we've got a
dimension that's big compared to the
sample size and as long as the energy in
this constant piece this epsilon piece
is small compared to the sample size
right not ridiculously small so we can't
for instance set epsilon into 0 right
and we just have this finite dimensional
thing but it can't be ridiculously small
but this is a you know very mild
condition it's exponentially small and
you know you can quantify things it's
the energy in that extra piece divided
by n plus n over the dimension right
and so you know if you think of some
rapidly decreasing sequence of
eigenvalues a covariance matrix that
looks like that and then we add in some
isotropic piece that's small but not
ridiculously small right then then it
feels much more like a more universal
phenomenon so we've got some small piece
of noise in all directions and you know
though but how how small it can be is is
no kind of constraint at all if you
think about it as something that perhaps
arises from numerical errors in doing
these finite dimensional computations
you know to get smaller than machine
precision
we just need kind of dozens of examples
for that for that sort of constraint
okay so let me quickly say a little bit
about actually I'm going to skip over
this so you can do things beyond the
Gaussian case there's one thing I want
to mention I guess so we need things to
be well specified we need we need to
have a linear model right the Y's the
conditional expectation of the Y's
should be this particular linear
function of it should be a linear
function of the X's and and we can deal
with sub Gaussian noise and sub Gaussian
X's crucial thing is that we need the
the X's to be a linear transformation of
a compactor with independent components
so we need a lot of independence in our
X's ok and that's crucial for what we're
doing so I'll mention this again a
little later actually right now so so
yeah so what can we say about the
misspecified case I think that's really
interesting where the conditional
expectation is some other function we
don't know how to do that what can we
say when we have less independence right
so for instance if the X's the the
elements of our hilbert space are
generated by through like represent a
function from an arc h s right then
we've got you know if k is if k is
smooth then we've got some d dimensional
manifold in an infinite dimensional
space ok and and you know what what can
we say in that sort of that's also
certainly not a linear transformation of
a vector with independent components and
there's some evidence that you know we
really do need
do need more independence and this sort
of thing provides so there's this paper
that Sasha and his student have that
show a particular example where you
cannot get near optimal predictive
accuracy in a fixed dimensional space in
where you take a fixed dimension
transform through a kernel okay so this
is a workshop on deep learning so I
should say a little bit about what we
can how things are related to deep
learning apart from of course you know
the very motivation for the problem
where it where it's arisen you know and
the the the short version of the story
is not very much right so so there's
this a whole spate of recent work on
viewing neural networks deep deep
networks as through their Taylor
expansion about the initial random
choice of parameters okay so think about
you know if you have a wide enough
randomly initialized network then you
know under appropriate conditions you
can show that the gradient descent
dynamics converge really quickly to a
minimum norm interpolating solution with
respect to a certain kernel so if we
have a two-layer thing with some initial
parameters here and some and some
non-linearity Sigma then you can define
a kernel that's that's based on this
inner product in the input space and you
know it's sort of a component wise
product of kernels and so you can think
of it as a linear classifiers but there
are no generalization results for
prediction rules of this kind that
interpolate noisy data in in in this
sort of a in this sort of a setting
where we're going to hear about the
asymptotic results of this of this form
I think in andreas talk later on okay so
so you know what doesn't apply in the
the non asymptotic case I thought I had
it on okay so what doesn't apply is we
don't have the the independence right we
don't have sufficient independence in
the in that in that case I do have it
right so you know what can we say about
the realistic case we we require
independent components for for the a
linear transformation of a vector with
independent components for our analysis
okay so and I think I still have a
couple of minutes yeah okay so I want to
say just just really a simple
observation about adversarial examples
if we're thinking of and again skipping
back to the to the linear case all of
the label noise is being injected into
the parameter estimates the theta hat
okay and and so it's no surprise in that
case that you can find directions in the
input space that line up with that label
noise vector or the thing corresponding
to the label noise vector right so we're
getting we've we've got this vector
epsilon that has you know a scale is a
there's an energy here that's
proportional to n so there's a direction
that corresponds to the transformation
of that of that noise vector that that
that gives us a that has a huge a huge
norm in our in our parameter estimate
and so even if moving in that direction
has no impact in the in the signal part
then we still have a huge sensitivity to
a perturbation in that direction
something that's big compared to you
know we get like a 1 over a term that
that's in the upper bound on on excess
risk so you know we have we have a
quantity that's growing like like the
actually there are there exponents
there's an extra exponent it should not
be there so we have a quantity that's
growing like in terms of the squared
squared error growing linearly within
which is terrible so ridiculous
sensitivity because we're taking all of
the noise in the in the labels and
injecting them into the injecting it
into the parameter estimates so we
should expect huge sensitivity in the
linear case okay so just to finish some
open open questions you know what
happens between this interpolation
regime or what what happens for instance
when we add a little bit of
regularization is it true that we can
always improve things with a bit of
regularization I think that's some very
interesting variant direction I mean
you're saying that this lack of
stability but on the other hand I mean
yeah you should write generalizations
right right right so this says that we
can find a direction so that if we
perturb our inputs in that direction we
have a huge sensitivity in our
predictions right our predictions can
change by an enormous amount the fact
that this can happen even though we have
a small excess risk means that that
direction is happening you know that
that perturbation is necessarily in a
direction where we never see any
significant variance right so with this
is an unnatural by definition an
unnatural example it's one that's very
unlikely
is that question here yeah good point
okay and and I guess key thing is
understanding what happens with with
deep networks how we can extend things
what's the analog of this minimum norm
linear prediction rule for realistic
deep networks you know and of course
this is a function of the optimization
method I think that's really fascinating
and what implications does it have for
regularization approaches for these
networks and and for robustness I mean I
think the adversarial example case is
really you know instructive all right so
just to sum up this is this is a setting
that's far from this classical regime of
a trade-off between fit to the training
data and complexity the kind of summary
of the result is we need this long flat
tail
of the eigenvalues of our covariance
matrix to get a minimum norm interpolant
predicting well so we have to have this
this high dimensional subspace where we
can hide all of the label noise you know
in our parameter estimates and have it
not affect our predictive accuracy lots
and lots of unimportant parameters but
you know one one consequence is we get
huge sensitivity to have a serial
perturbations I'll stop there
[Applause]
Shenzhen Commons offices with a - just
like Colonel learning with a specific
kernel so yes here you're estimating the
covariance matrix from samples but
suppose you have a kernel and suppose
you don't really know where the
underlying function if it can't be any
function and the function of course can
be composed into you is I can components
internally you have chosen so can you
say anything in that problem setting but
the results you have here right so so
the short answer is no not with not not
in this with the tools that we have what
what we've what we're relying on in the
case where we so so okay so the results
that that I presented for jointly
Gaussian XY you know in that setting
it's entirely these these second moments
of the exits right the sub Gaussian
setting what we need there is a linear
transformation of an independent vector
with independent components right and
the and the the x's that we see there a
sub Gaussian you know satisfied look
look in any direction and we get these
nice nice behavior of the tails that's
very different from taking you know
kernel function of X comma dot because
that's giving us a you know D
dimensional manifold in an infinite
dimensional space typically right which
is very far from that sort of that sort
of assumption so there is you know
they're sort of reasons to be hopeful
and reasons to be pessimistic in in that
sort of setting so I mentioned a result
that that Sasha has a negative result
that's if you take a look the plus
colonel in a fixed dimension right so
your mapping from from some constant
dimension into this infinite dimensional
space defined by this e to the minus
X minus y norm of X minus y then you get
there then you can show a Lobel they
show a lower bound on the excess risk in
that case all right you can't get below
a constant for constant dimension you
know as the dimension grows that lower
bound very rapidly decreases but but you
know for a fixed dimension you you you
really do have problems with that
with that requirement for independent so
I guess you can think of it that way I'm
sorry
it's only for that one one kernel there
are positive results but they're sort of
asymptotic as you increase the dimension
of the input then then good things
happen right and and and Draya and I
think Sasha are going to tell us about
about those but but yeah the the sort of
machinery we have forgetting no less and
tonic results that I don't I don't know
how to extend it to that sort of that
sort of case where we rely on a lot of
independents good question are there
examples in this case it's easy to make
your rule regression rule to be robust
to the second or third you can detect
yes you should it's quite yeah yeah it
is yeah right I mean I think yeah the
the linear case is is sort of very nice
in terms of being able to understand it
but and it's unclear how much it how it
relates to the deep learning situation
yeah okay
[Applause]